certes quelques années ici c'est l
autoroute de l'héroïne frappé durement
par le chômage les émeutes et le trafic
de drogue depuis des décennies une bonne
partie de camden s'est relevé au grand
bonheur de ce relais mais pour en
arriver là
la ville a pris les grands moyens en
2012 incapables de se sortir d'une
violence quotidienne dans ses rues et
aux prises avec un déficit monstre la
municipalité de moins de soixante
quatorze mille habitants a décidé de
dissoudre son service de police
licencié ses agents et de passer les
clés aux comptes et par rafael tentor
fait partie des policiers qui ont décidé
de repartir à zéro et qui ont accepté
des baisses de salaires pour regagner la
confiance des résidents et des
ambitieuses of touch donné le secret
d'un meilleur service de police un
entraînement constant des officiers xfx
qu est ce qui a changé ici c'est d'abord
une mission de police plus communautaire
les agents patrouillent sans cesse
créer des liens avec la population
qu'ils desservent et puis surtout les
tactiques pour arrêter un suspect ont
changé un nouveau code de conduite a été
adopté oui selon heather mills
depuis la refonte du service de police
les meurtres sont passés de 67 en 2012 à
25 en 2019
les cambriolages ont été réduits de
moitié
il est plein pour usage excessif de la
force ont fondu 2 95% de m
depuis la mort de trac freud aux mains
des policiers de minneapolis kardon est
perçu comme un modèle de réforme des
services de police ce qui est arrivé à
john floyd
selon raphaël personne n'aurait jamais
eu lieu dans sa ville
un mythe
évidemment tout n'est pas parfait loin
de là dans certains quartiers peu de
choses ont changé
maisons abandonnées institutions
violence et petite délinquance font
encore partie du quotidien ici cette
femme qui nous apostrophe dans la rue
résume la situation
ramsey qui fournit une meilleure police
c'est bien mais la recette magique pour
ici l'ensemble des états unis et
ailleurs pour soeur hélène qu'au bout du
compte depuis la refonte
le service de police a presque doublé
ses effectifs et son budget a augmenté
mais que ce soit à camden où ailleurs
aux états unis les défis dépassent
l'appétit pour ses réformes policières
les problèmes de pauvreté de santé
mentale et de drogue font aussi partie
des choses à changer et djoko n'y as pas
les séminaristes ya un jour à la fois le
modèle de camden se transforme en tout
cas les gens d'ici croient
[Musique]